Many people consider religion a source of comfort and strength, something they can turn to in difficult times. But religion and spirituality can also become sources of stress and conflict in people's lives. For example, when they wonder why God has allowed something terrible to happen, or when they feel rejected by their religious community. In the past few decades, psychologists have begun to explore the role that these spiritual struggles play in people's lives, and how spirituality and spiritual struggle affect our mental health and well-being. Today we're going to discuss some of those questions. What is spiritual struggle?
许多人认为宗教是安慰和力量的源泉，是他们在困难时期可以求助的对象。但宗教和灵性也可能成为人们生活中压力和冲突的来源。例如，当他们疑惑为什么上帝允许可怕的事情发生，或者当他们感到被宗教团体排斥时。在过去的几十年里，心理学家开始探索这些灵性挣扎在人们生活中所扮演的角色，以及灵性和灵性挣扎如何影响我们的心理健康和幸福感。今天我们将讨论其中一些问题。什么是灵性挣扎？
What does spiritual struggle look like for religious believers, atheists, and agnostics, and the growing number of people who consider themselves spiritual but not religious? How should psychologists and other mental health professionals think about the role of spirituality and mental health, and how should they address spirituality and religion with their patients? Finally, how does spirituality and belief in a supernatural power affect broader social issues such as political polarization? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Julie Exline, a professor in the Department of Psychological Sciences at Case Western Reserve University.
对于宗教信徒、无神论者、不可知论者，以及越来越多认为自己有灵性但没有宗教信仰的人来说，灵性挣扎是什么样的？心理学家和其他心理健康专业人士应该如何看待灵性和心理健康的作用，以及他们应该如何与患者探讨灵性和宗教问题？最后，灵性和对超自然力量的信仰如何影响政治极化等更广泛的社会问题？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是凯斯西储大学心理科学系的朱莉·埃克斯莱恩博士。
She has been studying spirituality and religion since the late 1990s with a particular interest in two topics, religious and spiritual struggles, and the causes and consequences of supernatural beliefs. Some of her recent projects include research on religious doubt and interpersonal struggles around religion and how those relate to people's decisions about whether to disengage from organized religion. She's also doing research on gratitude to God, demonic attributions, and perceptions of messages from religion. God or from people who have died. Dr. Exlein is a former president of APA's Division 36, the Society for the Psychology of Religion and Spirituality, and has won awards from that group, including the Margaret Gorman Early Career
她自20世纪90年代末以来一直致力于研究灵性和宗教，对两个主题特别感兴趣：宗教和灵性挣扎，以及超自然信仰的原因和后果。她最近的一些项目包括关于宗教怀疑、围绕宗教的人际冲突，以及这些如何影响人们关于是否脱离有组织宗教的决定。她还在研究对上帝的感恩、恶魔归因，以及对来自上帝或已故之人的信息的感知。埃克斯莱恩博士是美国心理学会第36分会（宗教与灵性心理学协会）的前任主席，并获得了该团体的多个奖项，包括玛格丽特·戈尔曼早期职业奖、弗吉尼亚·塞克斯顿指导奖和威廉·詹姆斯奖。
Award, the Virginia Sexton Mentoring Award, and the William James Award. Dr. Xline, thank you for joining me today. Thank you so much, Kim. I'm delighted to be here. Let's start by talking about how you define spiritual struggle in your real. research. Broadly speaking, what are spiritual struggles and what are some of the specific types of struggles you've identified in your research? So when we use the term spiritual struggle, we're basically talking about experiences that involve some kind of tension or conflict or strain around
埃克斯莱恩博士，感谢您今天参加我的节目。非常感谢，金。很高兴来到这里。让我们从您在研究中如何定义灵性挣扎开始谈起。广义上讲，什么是灵性挣扎？您在研究中确定了哪些具体的挣扎类型？当我们使用“灵性挣扎”这个术语时，我们基本上是在谈论那些涉及围绕宗教和灵性的某种紧张、冲突或压力的经历。
religion and spirituality. And importantly, this is something that people can experience regardless of whether they are religious or spiritual themselves. Some of the struggles that we've looked at are ones that involve supernatural beliefs. So we have divine struggles focused on a person's beliefs about God, like thinking that God is punishing you or that God is abandoned you or being angry at God. And then we have some of these demonic struggles, which of course require belief in the devil or demons or evil spirits, where you might feel like they're attacking you or tempting you or causing bad things to happen in your life. So those supernatural struggles clearly are ones that are going to be experienced by people who hold those
重要的是，无论人们自己是否有宗教信仰或灵性，他们都可能经历这种挣扎。我们研究过的一些挣扎涉及超自然信仰。因此，我们有针对个人对上帝信仰的神性挣扎，比如认为上帝在惩罚你，或者上帝抛弃了你，或者对上帝感到愤怒。然后我们还有一些恶魔挣扎，这当然需要相信魔鬼、恶魔或邪灵的存在，你可能会觉得它们在攻击你、诱惑你，或者导致你的生活中发生坏事。因此，这些超自然挣扎显然是那些持有特定信仰的人，以及通常是宗教人士所经历的。
specific beliefs and often by religious people. But we also have some struggles that are very common, regardless of whether people are religious or spiritual or not. So we have interpersonal struggles around religion. These are things like conflicts with other people around religious or spiritual teachings or beliefs. We also have doubt-related struggles where people are questioning, their beliefs. And we have ultimate meaning struggles where people might have questions about the ultimate meaning or purpose in their lives and moral struggles about trying to do what's right and wrong that anybody could have. Now, the U.S. in general is becoming a less religious country, at least in terms of affiliation with organized religion. One Pew Research Center poll found
但我们也发现了一些非常普遍的挣扎，无论人们是否有宗教信仰或灵性。例如围绕宗教的人际冲突。这些是与他人围绕宗教或灵性教义或信仰产生的冲突。我们还有与怀疑相关的挣扎，人们在质疑他们的信仰。我们还有终极意义挣扎，人们可能会对生命的终极意义或目的产生疑问；以及关于试图区分是非的道德挣扎，这是任何人都会有的。现在，美国总体上正在成为一个宗教色彩较淡的国家，至少在与有组织宗教的从属关系方面是这样。皮尤研究中心的一项民意调查发现，
that 29% of Americans said they had no religion in 2021, up from 16. percent in 2007. Do you think that spiritual struggles and spiritual questions in general are playing a smaller role in people's lives than they used to? Or are they something that's actually separate from organized religion? That's a great question. So some of the struggles that have to do with religious communities specifically, like feeling rejected or having conflicts with people within your religious community, those are going to be reduced if people have maybe left religion or aren't religious. But a lot of the struggles are ones that might cause people to leave religion. So they might be having questions about their beliefs. They might feel really turned off
2021年有29%的美国人表示他们没有宗教信仰，高于2007年的16%。您认为灵性挣扎和一般的灵性问题在人们生活中扮演的角色是否比过去小了？还是说它们实际上与有组织宗教是分开的？这是一个很好的问题。因此，一些专门与宗教团体有关的挣扎，比如感到被排斥或与宗教团体内部的人发生冲突，如果人们离开了宗教或不再信教，这些挣扎就会减少。但许多挣扎正是导致人们离开宗教的原因。所以他们可能会对自己的信仰产生疑问。他们可能会对某个宗教团体对某些敏感社会问题的看法，或者对个人强烈关注的问题（如移民权利、LGBTQ权利或政治问题）感到非常反感。
by maybe a religious group's opinion about some delicate social issue or something that a person feel strongly about like immigration rights or LGBTQ rights or political things. So a lot of times these struggles are part of what drive people out of religion. And a lot of times after people have left, my colleague Daryl Van Tongren has done some really cool research on what's called the religious residue effect, where when people have left religion, a lot of times, a lot of their values and beliefs, there's kind of a ghost of what was there when they're coming out of their religious lives. So a lot of the struggles that a person might have had around religion might not be completely resolved by leaving religion. And people who were never religious to start with
所以很多时候，这些挣扎是驱使人们离开宗教的部分原因。而且很多时候在人们离开后，我的同事达里尔·范·通格伦做了一些非常酷的研究，关于所谓的“宗教残留效应”，即当人们离开宗教后，很多时候，他们的许多价值观和信仰，在他们走出宗教生活时，依然存在着某种“幽灵”。因此，一个人在宗教方面可能经历的许多挣扎，并不会因为离开宗教而完全解决。而那些从一开始就没有宗教信仰的人，或者已经离开的人，
or who have left might still have spiritual struggles, but a lot of times they're going to be more about like anger at organized religion or questioning whether there's that ultimate meaning or purpose in your life. Because a lot of times religion helps to meet those needs for meaning and purpose for people. So when people have more freedom in their beliefs, that's great in some ways. And it can free you up from struggles around things like doctrine or high demand religious communities, but it can also have you feeling sort of a drift and might have a sense of a lack of community that you might be yearning for and might leave you with a sense that I'm not quite clear what my life is about anymore if it's not aligning with these religious beliefs and identities
可能仍然会有灵性挣扎，但很多时候，这些挣扎更多是关于对有组织宗教的愤怒，或者质疑生命中是否存在终极意义或目的。因为很多时候，宗教有助于满足人们对意义和目的的需求。所以当人们在信仰上有更多自由时，这在某些方面是件好事。它可以让你从教义或高要求宗教团体带来的挣扎中解脱出来，但它也可能让你感到某种漂泊，可能会让你感到缺乏你可能渴望的社区感，如果你的生活不再与你曾经珍视的那些宗教信仰和身份保持一致，可能会让你感到不再清楚自己的生活到底是为了什么。
that I used to hold deer. So overall, how common is it to experience spiritual struggles? What have you found in the surveys that you've done? So we've done some surveys looking at large groups of people in the U.S., say around 20,000 people. Around 60 to 70% are saying that they've had spiritual struggles recently. And on a lifetime item, again, around 70% are saying that they've had spiritual struggles at some point in their lives. So when we define struggles in these broader ways, it's really clear that a lot of people are experiencing struggles around religion and spirituality.
那么总的来说，经历灵性挣扎有多普遍？您在所做的调查中发现了什么？我们进行了一些调查，观察了美国的大群体，比如大约2万人。大约60%到70%的人表示他们最近有过灵性挣扎。而在终身项目上，同样有大约70%的人表示他们在生命中的某个时刻有过灵性挣扎。因此，当我们以这些更广泛的方式定义挣扎时，很明显，许多人都在经历围绕宗教和灵性的挣扎。
Can religion actually be the cause of spiritual struggles? And if that's the case, how can people work through their angst without leaving the faith that caused them the problem? A lot of times people's struggles do come specifically from the teachings of a religion, say trying to follow a religious text or authority that's saying this is the way it is or this is straight from the mouth of God and you might disagree with those things or you might just find them really difficult to live with. So for example, I was raised in a fundamentalist Christian tradition where we believed that everyone was going to hell unless they held specific beliefs.
宗教真的会成为灵性挣扎的根源吗？如果是这样，人们如何在不放弃导致他们问题的信仰的情况下解决他们的焦虑？很多时候，人们的挣扎确实直接源于宗教的教义，比如试图遵循一个宗教文本或权威，它说“这就是真理”或“这是上帝亲口说的”，而你可能不同意这些事情，或者你可能只是觉得它们很难接受。例如，我是在一个原教旨主义基督教传统中长大的，我们相信除非持有特定信仰，否则每个人都会下地狱，
or went through a specific conversion experience. And I can tell you that that was a major source of spiritual struggles for me and probably a big part of why I'm doing this work today. So it's very challenging sometimes when the struggles come from the beliefs themselves and the teachings themselves, a lot of times people have to have the openness and to feel safe enough to question the beliefs, which often is difficult to do,
或者经历过特定的皈依体验。我可以告诉你，那是我灵性挣扎的主要来源，也可能是我今天从事这项工作的重要原因。所以，当挣扎源于信仰本身和教义本身时，有时是非常具有挑战性的。很多时候，人们必须有开放的心态，并感到足够安全去质疑这些信仰，这在一个非常基于权威的传统中通常很难做到。
in a very authority-based tradition. And then a lot of times there needs to be kind of a sifting of what do I really believe, what makes sense to me, and which beliefs are even going to work for me psychologically. So for me, that belief that pretty much everyone was going to hell except a select few was really psychologically damaging. So that's something that I had to reassess. But in the type of church that I was raised in, it would not have been seen as acceptable. to question that authority. It would have been like, yeah, this is upsetting, but it's just the way that it is.
而且很多时候，需要对“我真正相信什么”、“什么对我来说是有意义的”，以及“哪些信仰在心理上对我有效”进行某种筛选。所以对我来说，那种除了少数人外几乎每个人都会下地狱的信仰，在心理上确实具有破坏性。所以这是我必须重新评估的事情。但在我长大的那种教会里，质疑那种权威是不会被视为可以接受的。它会被认为是：“是的，这很令人不安，但事实就是这样。”
So this can be very hard for people to navigate when you're trying to respect sources of religious authority and maybe believing that this is really the way it is. And some of the beliefs are really frightening or difficult or might cause you to judge certain groups of people negatively. You know, when it's coming straight out of the religious text, this causes a lot of stress for people if they want to be nice to people and not judge them. Do atheists experience spiritual struggles? Is this something that's relevant to non-believers, or maybe they do, but they call them something else?
所以，当你试图尊重宗教权威来源，并可能相信这确实是事实时，人们很难处理这些问题。而且有些信仰确实令人恐惧或困难，或者可能导致你对他人的某些群体做出负面评价。你知道，当它直接来自宗教文本时，如果人们想善待他人而不去评判他们，这会给他们带来很大的压力。无神论者会经历灵性挣扎吗？这对非信徒来说是相关的吗？或者也许他们会经历，但他们称之为其他东西？
When we first started studying anger at God about 20 years ago, we were initially going to leave atheists and agnostics out of that study completely because we thought, well, they don't believe in God. It's not going to be relevant for them. But we allowed everybody to take the survey just to see what happened. What we found was that a lot of atheists and agnostics actually did say that they felt some anger toward God. So that got us really looking at these things more closely. What we find is that atheists and agnostics often experience spiritual struggles around things like ultimate meaning, anger at organized religion, these interpersonal conflicts around religion. They're going to have some of these questions maybe about whether they're belief,
大约20年前，当我们开始研究对上帝的愤怒时，我们最初打算完全将无神论者和不可知论者排除在研究之外，因为我们认为，好吧，他们不相信上帝。这对他们来说不会有意义。但我们允许所有人参加调查，只是为了看看会发生什么。我们发现，许多无神论者和不可知论者实际上确实表示他们对上帝感到某种愤怒。这让我们开始更仔细地审视这些事情。我们发现，无神论者和不可知论者经常围绕终极意义、对有组织宗教的愤怒、围绕宗教的人际冲突等问题经历灵性挣扎。他们可能会对自己的信仰是否正确产生一些疑问，
correct, they're going to have moral struggles. They're not usually going to have struggles about the devil, but sometimes there are still some struggles about God because people, especially if they are people who have left religion, they might still have these bad memories about, you know, I prayed for my grandma to be healed and she died, or they'll remember how they felt let down by God or punished by God. So they might, some might not want to believe in God, but there's still this residue that's left where there might still be some energy for a person. We also found, this is in a study that we did a few years ago, that Erin Sedler was the first author on this paper. We found that just like with religious people, religious and spiritual struggles were quite common among atheists,
他们会有道德挣扎。他们通常不会有关于魔鬼的挣扎，但有时仍然会有关于上帝的挣扎，因为人们，特别是如果他们是离开宗教的人，他们可能仍然有这些糟糕的记忆，比如“我祈祷我的祖母康复，但她去世了”，或者他们会记得他们感到被上帝辜负或被上帝惩罚的感觉。所以有些人可能不想相信上帝，但仍然有这种残留，一个人可能仍然会有某种情绪。我们还发现，这是我们在几年前做的一项研究，艾琳·塞德勒是这篇论文的第一作者。我们发现，就像宗教人士一样，宗教和灵性挣扎在无神论者中也相当普遍，
and they had the same kinds of correlates with mental health. So for atheists, too, spiritual struggles are correlated with more anxiety, depression, stress, lower levels of life meaning and things like that. So you mentioned anger at God a moment ago, which is, I understand, a very common spiritual struggle. And in some ways, it's analogous to being angry at another person. How does spiritual struggle mirror and differ from other kinds of interpersonal conflicts? For many people, there's a perceived relationship with God that in some important ways is really parallel to human relationships. So people are more likely to be angry at God for the same reasons they would get angry at another person. If they think that God is being unfair or arbitrary, if they think that God has an intention to harm,
而且它们与心理健康有着相同的相关性。因此，对于无神论者来说，灵性挣扎也与更多的焦虑、抑郁、压力、较低的生活意义水平等相关。您刚才提到了对上帝的愤怒，据我了解，这是一种非常常见的灵性挣扎。在某种程度上，它类似于对另一个人感到愤怒。灵性挣扎如何反映并区别于其他人际冲突？对许多人来说，存在一种感知的与上帝的关系，在某些重要方面确实与人际关系平行。所以人们更有可能因为他们会对另一个人感到愤怒的同样原因而对上帝感到愤怒。如果他们认为上帝是不公平或武断的，如果他们认为上帝有伤害的意图，
if they think that God clearly caused something that was negative, and maybe if the person felt entitled to have something go their way, these are the same reasons that people get angry at other people. And then there are all these other dynamics that happen for people that are more positive, like feeling grateful to God or having a sense of attachment to God. But there are some really important differences in the relationships, clearly because most people don't report being able to see God or hear God or experience God with their senses. So they might be going based on inferences from their own life experiences,
如果他们认为上帝显然导致了负面的事情，也许如果这个人觉得理应得到某种结果，这些都是人们对他人感到愤怒的同样原因。然后还有所有其他对人们来说更积极的动态，比如对上帝感到感恩或有一种对上帝的依恋感。但这些关系中确实存在一些非常重要的差异，显然是因为大多数人报告说无法看到上帝、听到上帝或用感官体验上帝。所以他们可能基于对自己生活经历的推断，
but a lot of it is going to come out of teachings and social input that they're getting from other people about what God is like coming down through some kind of authority source. So there's all this mystery around what God is like. And then there's that huge issue of authority and power. You know, there's just a little bit of a power differential between people and God. And that's going to make a big difference in terms of how people are going to relate to God versus others. So in a sense, it can be like this virtual relationship. that people might not be sure if it's real or not. And if it is real, well, this is a pretty
但很多时候，它将来自教义和社会输入，他们从其他人那里得到的关于上帝是什么样的信息，通过某种权威来源传达下来。所以关于上帝是什么样子的，存在着所有的神秘感。然后是权威和权力的巨大问题。你知道，人和上帝之间确实存在一点权力差异。这将在人们如何与上帝而非他人建立关系方面产生巨大差异。所以从某种意义上说，这可能就像这种虚拟关系，
significant relationship if God has as much power and control and wisdom as people tend to think that God does if they believe in God. Now, you recently co-authored a book on working with spiritual struggles in psychotherapy. Why do you think this is important for mental health professionals to consider and how prepared are most of them to have these conversations with their patients? So one thing that we've found very, very consistently is that spiritual struggles are not only correlated with things like depression and anxiety and stress, but there's evidence through longitudinal studies that spiritual struggles are sometimes primary, meaning that the anger at God at time one is predicting increases in depression between time one and time two.
人们可能不确定它是真实的还是虚构的。如果它是真实的，好吧，如果上帝像人们倾向于认为的那样拥有那么多的权力、控制力和智慧（如果他们相信上帝的话），那么这就是一种非常重要的关系。现在，您最近合著了一本关于在心理治疗中处理灵性挣扎的书。您为什么认为这对心理健康专业人士来说很重要？他们中有多少人准备好与患者进行这些对话？我们非常一致地发现的一件事是，灵性挣扎不仅与抑郁、焦虑和压力等事物相关，而且通过纵向研究有证据表明，灵性挣扎有时是首要的，这意味着在时间点1对上帝的愤怒预示着在时间点1和时间点2之间抑郁症的增加。
So if you're angry at God, you might get more depressed later. There's lots of evidence for those kinds of relationships. So a lot of therapists tend to be less religious than the general population. This is definitely true for psychologists, much less religious on average than the general population. So a lot of times there might be some kind of a hesitation where even if a therapist might see spiritual struggles as being important, they might be reluctant going into this area and delving into these types of questions. They might be concerned that they'll be expected to come up with religious answers for things. They might have an anti-religious bias in some case and they're afraid that it will show through or that it will lead to a
所以如果你对上帝感到愤怒，你以后可能会变得更抑郁。有很多证据支持这类关系。因此，许多治疗师往往比一般人群的宗教信仰要淡薄。对于心理学家来说，这绝对是事实，平均而言比一般人群的宗教信仰要淡薄得多。所以很多时候可能会有一种犹豫，即使治疗师可能认为灵性挣扎很重要，他们也可能不愿进入这个领域并深入探讨这些类型的问题。他们可能担心会被要求对事情给出宗教答案。在某些情况下，他们可能有反宗教偏见，担心它会显露出来，或者导致与客户的裂痕。
a rift with the client. And this is where some of the recent training that's been happening and the great books being written on things like spiritually integrated therapy. My colleague Ken Parggement wrote a great book on that and a really nice line of work on spiritual competencies that's evolving. Some really nice funded projects are happening in this area. These are things that are going to be resources for clinicians so that they'll be more comfortable talking with people. people about spiritual issues in treatment. But the connections with mental health are very clear and consistent. And again, there is that evidence. This is from a meta-analysis that Margaret Bacrest was the first author on. There's good evidence that, yes, spiritual struggles can actually lead to
这就是最近发生的一些培训以及关于“灵性整合治疗”等主题的优秀书籍发挥作用的地方。我的同事肯·帕格门特写了一本关于此的好书，并且在灵性能力方面有一条非常好的工作线正在发展。一些非常好的资助项目正在这个领域进行。这些将成为临床医生的资源，使他们能够更自在地与人们谈论治疗中的灵性问题。但与心理健康的联系是非常清晰和一致的。同样，有证据支持这一点。这是玛格丽特·巴克雷斯特作为第一作者的一项荟萃分析。有充分的证据表明，是的，灵性挣扎确实会导致心理健康问题。
mental health problems. There's an idea that religious people are generally happier or more content than people who aren't religious. Is that born out? in the research? There is some research suggesting that people who are more religious live longer. They have better health behaviors in some areas. They have better self-control. But a general relationship with happiness is something that's more elusive. There are these connections with things like better physical health, for example,
有一种观点认为，宗教人士通常比不信教的人更快乐或更满足。这在研究中得到了证实吗？有一些研究表明，更虔诚的人寿命更长。他们在某些领域的健康行为更好。他们有更好的自我控制能力。但与幸福的一般关系是更难以捉摸的。它与更好的身体健康等事物之间存在联系，
and some indicators of greater well-being. being. A lot of it seems to have to do with the meaning-making function that religion provides, and also with the sense of community or social support that people get from religion. But a lot of the benefits that are more psychological, the meaning-making functions, people will turn to other types of ideologies, belief systems, or spiritual beliefs that are more personally tailored, where they don't have to always go to organized religion to find those answers. And for an increasing number of people, they're wanting that flexibility of, yes, I do believe in something transcendent. I believe in the divine. I believe that we're all interconnected. I maybe
以及一些更高幸福感的指标。很多似乎与宗教提供的意义构建功能有关，也与人们从宗教中获得的社区感或社会支持有关。但许多更具心理层面的益处，即意义构建功能，人们会转向其他类型的意识形态、信仰体系或更个性化的灵性信仰，他们不必总是去有组织的宗教中寻找这些答案。对于越来越多的人来说，他们想要那种灵活性，即“是的，我确实相信某种超越性的东西。我相信神性。我相信我们都是相互联系的。我可能
believe specifically in God or an afterlife, but I don't want to have to go along with the teachings of a specific religion that I might not agree with. Now, in addition to the research that you've done around spiritual struggles. You have also done a lot of work in supernatural attributions or people's beliefs that events have supernatural causes. What are the kinds of things that people tend to attribute to supernatural causes? And why do they do this? People often see the supernatural as being very involved in their day-to-day lives, depending on their belief system. So if someone thinks that God or the devil or spirits not only exist but are powerful and are active in the world and are actively trying to do things here and communicate with people, it's not much of a stretch to think that a certain event that happens in your day might be a message from God, or it might be kind of a wink from a deceased loved one. Or if something bad happens, there might be not much of a stretch to say, oh,
特别相信上帝或来世，但我不想必须遵循我可能不同意的特定宗教的教义。”现在，除了您在灵性挣扎方面所做的研究之外，您还在超自然归因或人们认为事件有超自然原因的信仰方面做了大量工作。人们倾向于将哪些事情归因于超自然原因？他们为什么要这样做？人们通常认为超自然力量非常参与他们的日常生活，这取决于他们的信仰体系。因此，如果有人认为上帝、魔鬼或灵体不仅存在，而且强大且活跃在世界上，并积极试图在这里做事情并与人交流，那么认为你一天中发生的某件事可能是来自上帝的信息，或者可能是已故亲人的某种暗示，这并不奇怪。或者如果发生了坏事，认为“我认为是魔鬼导致了这件事”或“邪灵对此负责”，这也不奇怪。
I think that the devil is causing this or that evil spirits are responsible for this. A lot of it has to do with these specific beliefs about these entities having these abilities. We call these they're supernatural operating rules. So if you think that God or the devil or spirits are out there operating in the world and doing all these things, then it's not at all a stretch to think that, oh, they're affecting things in the world and causing things to happen. in a person's life. One important thing here is that you might think, well, a person would only assume that God was involved if something really dramatic happened that seemed to violate natural laws. Something like the type of miracle that got reported in the Bible, Moses parting the Red Sea
很多时候，这与关于这些实体拥有这些能力的特定信仰有关。我们称之为“超自然操作规则”。所以如果你认为上帝、魔鬼或灵体在世界上运作并做所有这些事情，那么认为它们正在影响世界上的事情并导致你生活中的事情发生，这完全不奇怪。这里重要的一点是，你可能会想，好吧，一个人只有在发生了看起来违反自然规律的非常戏剧性的事情时，才会假设上帝参与其中。比如《圣经》中报道的那种奇迹，摩西在上帝的帮助下分开红海，诸如此类的事情。但因为人们经常看到超自然力量通过自然事件间接地工作，在幕后做这些微妙的事情，
with God's help, that sort of thing. But because people often see supernatural forces working indirectly through natural events, kind of behind the scenes doing these subtle things, something doesn't have to violate natural laws or even seem to in order for somebody to see God or the devil or the spirits being involved with it. So there could be something like seeing a rainbow, seeing a certain animal, having something that happens in a day repeatedly, like a word that keeps coming up, where people are often searching for meaning behind these events, and especially if you've been socialized through religious or spiritual beliefs or other people around you to think, oh, our loved ones give us
所以某件事不必违反自然规律，甚至看起来不必违反，某人就能看到上帝、魔鬼或灵体参与其中。所以可能就像看到彩虹、看到某种动物、一天中反复发生的事情，比如一个不断出现的词，人们经常在这些事件背后寻找意义，特别是如果你通过宗教或灵性信仰或周围的人被社会化，认为“哦，我们的亲人在他们离开后会给我们发信息”。如果一个你信任的人说，“哦，这就是我解读这些动物目击事件或这些出现的不同事物或随机在收音机上播放的歌曲的方式”，这就会变得合理。如果一个你信任的人似乎做出了这些类型的归因或解释，它看起来会更可信。
messages after they go. It's going to be reasonable to think that if someone that you trust has said, oh, that's how I interpret these animal sightings or these different things that come up or these songs that come on the radio randomly. If somebody that you trust seems to make these types of attributions or explanations, it's going to seem like something that's more plausible to believe. And there's also for many people a strong desire to want to believe that our loved ones still live and exist on the other side or to believe in a God who loves us and comforts us. And that desire is another big driver. So in order to see a supernatural explanation for something, it has to seem at least somewhat plausible logically. So it's not like we just check our
而且对于许多人来说，有一种强烈的愿望，想要相信我们的亲人仍然活着并存在于另一边，或者相信一位爱我们并安慰我们的上帝。这种愿望是另一个巨大的驱动力。因此，为了对某事看到超自然解释，它在逻辑上至少必须看起来有点合理。所以并不是说我们只是把大脑抛在脑后。它必须看起来像，基于我认为超自然实体如何运作的方式，我认为这可能会发生。如果存在那种愿望，人们就更有可能做出归因。不，我真的想相信这一点。这增加了燃料。它使人更有可能倾向于超自然解释，而不是想要驳回它。我还要简要说明的一件事是，在某些情况下，心理健康状况也会产生影响。
brains at the door. It has to seem like, based on how I think supernatural entities work, I think this could happen. And people are going to be more likely to make the attributions if there's that desire. No, I really would like to believe this. That kind of adds fuel to it. It makes it more likely that the person is going to lean toward a supernatural explanation as opposed to wanting to dismiss it. One other thing I should say just really briefly is that there are some cases where mental health conditions can feed in as well. So clearly, some people who are having dissociative disorders or a psychotic disorder are going to see things, hear things, have experiences that are unusual that might set the stage for more supernatural attributions too.
所以显然，一些患有解离性障碍或精神病性障碍的人会看到事物、听到声音、有不寻常的经历，这也可能为更多的超自然归因奠定基础。但我们在工作中试图澄清的一个非常重要的事情是，拥有你视为超自然的经历并不一定就是心理障碍的迹象。但那个阈值在哪里？那么心理学家或心理健康提供者如何能够判断某人已经超越了那种对安慰的需求？比如“我看到了一只红雀，那是我的母亲在对我说话”，而不是一个心理上真正崩溃的人？
But one really important thing that we're trying to clarify in our work is that having an experience that you see as supernatural is not necessarily a sign of a psychological disorder. But where is that threshold? So how would a psychologist or a mental health provider be able to tell that someone has gone beyond just that need for comfort? Like I saw a cardinal and that was my mother speaking to me, as opposed to somebody who has really had a break psychologically?
这就是良好的评估技能发挥作用的地方，也就是一般的临床评估技能。你必须观察这种信仰似乎如何与这个人的其他想法相吻合。他们的其他想法看起来是否合理、有序？他们看起来是否有偏执或夸大的想法？他们看起来是否有许多不寻常的经历？然后，如果你看到这些其他可能的不寻常思维或围绕这些想法的极端痛苦的指标，你可能会更深入地进行评估，对心理症状进行更深入的评估。
this is where good assessment skills come in, just general clinical assessment skills. You have to look at how this belief seems to be fitting in with the person's other thoughts. Do their other thoughts seem like they're reasonably organized, orderly? Do they seem like they're having paranoid or grandiose thoughts? Do they seem like they're having a lot of unusual experiences? then if you see these other indicators of maybe unusual thinking or extreme distress around these thoughts, you might go a little more deep into your assessment with a more in-depth assessment of psychological symptoms.
在某些情况下，也许需要进行医学评估，可能存在癫痫或肿瘤等导致这些事情的原因。所以这就是为什么真正了解你正在交谈的人并拥有那些良好的评估技能很重要，当你听到超自然经历时，试着真正尽可能多地了解它，了解导致它的原因，了解这个人对其他事情的想法的质量。你知道，他们在思考其他事情时看起来是否清晰？然后你可以根据需要跟进更多细节以试图找出答案。
And in some cases, perhaps a medical assessment, there could be something like epilepsy or a tumor or something that's causing these things. So this is where it's important to just really get to know. person that you're talking with and to have those good assessment skills where you, when you hear about a supernatural experience, just try to really find out as much as you can about it, about what led up to it, about the quality of the person's thoughts about other things. You know, are they seeming like they're thinking clearly about other things? And then you can follow up if needed with more detail to try to find out.
因为你当然不想进入一种情况并错过某种严重的疾病，比如精神分裂症，因为你说“哦，所有的超自然东西都没问题”。但与此同时，许多临床医生，特别是心理学家和精神科医生，倾向于自动驳回诸如“亲人正在与某人交谈”之类的信仰，将其视为幻觉。这就是许多人所担心的。他们害怕告诉治疗师或医生，因为他们会认为我疯了。
because you certainly don't want to go into a situation and miss some type of serious condition like schizophrenia because you're saying, oh, all of the supernatural stuff is fine. But at the same time, a tendency that many clinicians have psychologists and psychiatrists in particular is going to be to automatically dismiss things like these beliefs that a loved one is talking to a person, to dismiss them as hallucinations. And this is what a lot of people are worried about. They're afraid to tell therapists or doctors because they're going to think I'm crazy.
所以这是我们试图帮助临床医生变得更细致入微的部分原因。是的，可能正在发生一些表明可能需要治疗的心理问题的事情，但在许多情况下并非如此。在许多情况下，相信收到来自上帝或已故亲人的信息，或相信某事是因果报应，对人们来说可能非常有帮助、治愈和激励作用。
So this is part of what we're trying to help clinicians be more nuanced about. Yes, there might be something going on that would indicate a psychological problem that might need treatment, but in many cases there is not. And in a lot of situations, a belief of having received a message from God or a deceased loved one or a belief that something is karma can be really helpful and healing and motivating for people.
所以重要的是不要直接驳回这些事情。现在，我们谈论的是更积极的超自然归因，但也有一些人也相信恶魔归因，我想知道，如果人们开始将各种行为归因于“魔鬼正在导致某事发生”或“魔鬼正在让我做某事”，这是否是一个更令人担忧的迹象？关于人们在事物背后看到魔鬼或邪灵的整个问题，还没有像关于上帝的信仰那样被研究得那么多。这是我们刚刚开始更多关注的事情。显然，对于许多人来说，相信魔鬼在诱惑
So it's important to not dismiss these things out of hand. Now, we're talking about supernatural attributions that are more positive, but there are some people who also believe in demonic attribution, and I'm wondering, is that perhaps a more concerning sign if people begin to ascribe all kinds of behaviors to the fact that the devil is making something happen or the devil is making me do something. This whole question about people seeing the devil or evil spirits behind things is one that hasn't been studied nearly as much as beliefs about God. And it's something that we're just starting to look at more. Clearly, for a lot of people, believing that the devil is tempting
或攻击他们，或导致世界上的负面事件，只是他们宗教信仰体系的一部分。所以这可能只是“世界就是这样运作的”的一部分，做出这些对魔鬼的归因可能并不特别令人痛苦。但在某些情况下，如果一个人真的感到被魔鬼伤害，比如“我担心我自己可能会走向黑暗面”，或者“我担心魔鬼比我强大，魔鬼会把我从上帝身边带走”，这真的可能导致一种恐惧感，即你最终会下地狱，或者因为你跟随魔鬼而做出可怕的事情。我认为这就是我很多兴趣所在，不仅仅是在人们认为魔鬼可能影响他们的个人信仰上，
or attacking them or causing negative events in the world is just part of their religious belief system. So it might just be part of this is how the world works, and it might not be especially distressing to make these attributions to the devil. But in some cases, if a person feels really victimized by the devil, like I'm afraid that maybe I'm going to over to the dark side myself, or I'm afraid that the devil is stronger than me and the devil is going to take me away from God, that could really lead to a sense of terror that you're going to end up in hell or end up doing terrible things because you're following the devil. And I think this is where a lot of my interest is not so much just in people's personal beliefs that the devil might be influencing them,
而是在人们说别人跟随魔鬼时对他们做出的判断。现在，这已经有了研究，观察政治问题、离婚，如果你认为你与之争论的人正在跟随魔鬼，你可以看到这如何真正为你的观点增加了很大的力度，即他们是错误的，甚至可能导致危险的方向……是的，这给了你正当理由，当然。是的，它甚至可能使这个人看起来是邪恶的。鉴于人类已经有的去人格化他人的倾向，
but in the judgments that people make of other people when they say that they're following the devil. Now, this is something where there have been studies done looking at political issues, divorce, if you think that somebody who you're disagreeing with is following the devil, you can see how that really adds a lot of oomph to your opinions that they are in the wrong and could even lead down a dangerous direction of... Yeah, it gives you justification, sure. Yes, it could even make it seem like this other person is evil. And given the tendencies that humans already have to depersonalize others,
以及具有攻击性，还有什么比指责他们跟随魔鬼并成为邪恶更能证明对另一个人或群体的攻击是正当的呢？你可以看到在极端情况下，这是一种可能导致人们采取非常激进行为的心态，甚至可能想要消灭他人，因为毕竟，你是在与邪恶作斗争。所以我们想在这方面做更多的工作，但有一些很好的证据表明，这些关于他人的恶魔归因与攻击性行为之间存在联系，我认为这在心理上非常非常重要。您写过关于您对濒死和共享死亡体验、迷幻之旅以及对死后交流的感知的迷恋，这些是许多人视为通往其他维度的门户的事物。
and to be aggressive, what could better justify aggression toward another person or group than accusing them of following the devil and being evil? You could see at its extremes that this is the kind of mindset that could lead people toward very aggressive behavior, maybe even wanting to annihilate others, because after all, you're in a fight against evil. So we want to do more work on this, but there is some good evidence for links between these demonic attributions about other people and aggressive behaviors that I think is really, really important psychologically. You've written about your fascination with near-death and shared death experiences, psychedelic journeys, and perceptions of after-death communication, the types of things that many people see as doorways to other dimensions.
您能告诉我们的听众一点关于您是如何研究这些概念以及您发现了什么吗？我真的对人们解释为暗示某种超越这个世界的世界的经历很着迷。所以对一些人来说，这些是濒死体验，某人可能会心脏病发作，比如说，并有一次惊人的经历，也许悬浮在身体上方，看到房间里发生了什么，被亲人迎接，或精神向导穿过隧道，去另一个地方，有成千上万这样的叙述。国际濒死研究协会是这里对于那些有过这些经历的人来说的一个很好的资源。现在我们知道如何把人救回来，它们变得更普遍了
Can you tell our listeners a little bit about how you're studying these concepts and what you're finding? I'm really fascinated with people's experiences that they interpret as suggesting some type of world beyond this one. So for some people, these are these near-death experiences where somebody might have a heart attack, say, and have an amazing experience, maybe hovering above their body, seeing what's going on in the room, being met by loved ones. or spirit guides going down a tunnel, going to another place, there are thousands of accounts of these. The International Association for Near Death Studies is a great resource here for people who've had these experiences. They've become more common now that we know how to bring people back
从心脏骤停中恢复。所以更多的人处于可以回来的情况。当然，关于这些是否真的暗示了另一种代谢、物理现实，还是仅仅是身体正在做的事情，存在很多争议。所以这不是我关注那么多的领域。那不是我的专长。但我确实对那些有过这些濒死体验或共享死亡体验的人非常感兴趣，意思是说你可能在某人的临终床边，目睹他们的灵魂离开他们的身体，或者甚至陪伴他们
from cardiac arrest. So more people are in the situation where they can come back. And of course, there's a lot of controversy around whether these are actually suggesting another metabolic, physical reality or whether it's just something that the body is doing. So that's not the area that I've focused on as much. That's not my wheelhouse. But I am very interested in how people who have had these near-death experiences or a shared death experience, meaning you might be at the deathbed of somebody and witness their spirit leaving their body or maybe even accompanying them
去这个其他世界短暂地回来。有一些关于这些类型经历的非常酷的故事。甚至人们有冥想体验或迷幻体验，也可以有这些深刻的相遇，同样，他们感知到是与神圣的存在、已故的亲人、有时是恶魔力量在一起，或者有这种对超越的世界或万物相互联系的深刻感，这真的可以改变生活。我之所以对这些事情如此感兴趣，部分原因是因为对于许多人来说，这些类型的经历可能有助于为那些不属于有组织宗教传统的人提供灵性意义。我甚至想知道它们是否在某些情况下可能有助于解决灵性挣扎，
to this other world briefly and coming back. There are some really cool stories about those types of experiences. And even people having meditation experiences or psychedelic experiences can have these profound encounters that, again, they perceive as being with divine beings, deceased loved ones, sometimes demonic forces, or having this profound sense of a world beyond or the interconnectedness of all things that can be really life-changing. Part of the reason I'm so interested in these things is because for a lot of people, these types of experiences might help to give spiritual meaning for people who are not part of an organized religious tradition. And I even wonder if they might help to resolve spiritual struggles in some cases
通过给人们希望，即存在某种我们可以共享的充满爱的、相互联系的终极现实。这真的会有帮助。所以例如，正如我在过去十年左右在自己的生活中考虑过这样的想法一样，它真的帮助我有一种感觉，好吧，如果存在来世，它不一定非要是这种天堂或地狱的事情。还有所有这些其他的可能性。而且我发现其中很多更令人安慰。我认为考虑它的证据确实非常有趣。
by giving people hope of some loving, interconnected, ultimate reality that we can all share in. and that could really help. So for example, as I've entertained ideas like this in the last decade or so in my own life, it's really helped me to have a sense of, okay, if there's an afterlife, it doesn't just have to be this heaven or hell thing. There are all these other possibilities. And a lot of this I find much more comforting. And I think the evidence for it is really interesting to consider.
通过给予人们对某种我们可以共享的、充满爱与相互联系的终极现实的希望。这真的会有所帮助。例如，在过去十年左右的时间里，当我在自己的生活中思考这类想法时，它确实帮助我产生了一种感觉，即如果真的有来世，它不一定非得是天堂或地狱。还有各种其他的可能性。我发现其中很多想法要令人宽慰得多。而且我认为，考虑这些想法背后的证据是非常有趣的。
So just to wrap up, what questions are you working on now? What are the next big issues you would like to have answered? A few things we're looking at now are whether people can forgive religious communities that have hurt them, let's say that you decided to leave or you decided to stay. Can you set boundaries about what you believe and what you don't and even allow yourself to have. some anger, but be able to let go of that anger at an appropriate time where it's not holding you back. Because a lot of times when people have left religion, they're very angry, understandably, but people can kind of get stuck in that anger. I have a kind of a long research history with the topic of forgiveness, which we didn't talk about today. So we're interested in applying that. I'm also really interested in people's experiences of after-death communication. Kathleen Pate, a grad
总结一下，您目前正在研究哪些问题？您希望接下来解决哪些重大议题？我们目前正在关注的一些事情包括：人们是否能够原谅曾经伤害过他们的宗教团体，假设您决定离开或决定留下。您是否可以为自己的信仰设定界限，允许自己产生一些愤怒，但又能在适当的时候放下这些愤怒，而不让它阻碍您前进？因为很多时候，当人们离开宗教时，他们会感到非常愤怒，这是可以理解的，但人们有时会陷入这种愤怒中无法自拔。我在宽恕这一课题上有很长的研究历史，我们今天没有谈到这一点。所以我们有兴趣将其应用到研究中。我还对人们关于死后交流的经历非常感兴趣。凯瑟琳·佩特（Kathleen Pate），一位与我合作的研究生，
student who works with me did her master's on that. We plan to do more work in that area. We're looking with Will Skut, who's working with me, we are looking at the question of whether psychedelics might trigger spiritual struggles or help to resolve spiritual struggles in some people. And we're also really interested in these questions about political polarization and how supernatural beliefs and attributions could either make people more or less polarized, depending on their content. So I like to think about supernatural beliefs as being sort of an accelerant. Like they make your love or hatred of another person stronger by providing this connection
完成了关于这一课题的硕士论文。我们计划在该领域开展更多工作。我们正在与威尔·斯库特（Will Skut）合作，他与我一起工作，我们正在研究迷幻药是否会引发某些人的精神挣扎，或者帮助他们解决精神挣扎。我们还对政治极化问题非常感兴趣，以及超自然信仰和归因如何根据其内容使人们变得更加极化或不那么极化。所以我喜欢把超自然信仰看作是一种催化剂。它们通过提供这种联系，使您对他人的爱或恨变得更强烈，
to an authority beyond this world. So I think that depending on whether your belief is that other people you disagree with are to be met with love and respect, or if you think they're to be met with, hostility and a sense that God is on our side. You know, in either case, having a divine endorsement for whatever you think about these other people could really push things in the direction of more love, forgiveness, and connection, or more hatred and polarization and aggression. That all sounds remarkably interesting.
这种联系指向超越这个世界的权威。所以我认为，取决于您的信仰是认为您不同意的人应该以爱和尊重来对待，还是认为应该以敌意来对待，并认为上帝站在我们这一边。您知道，无论哪种情况，为您的想法提供神圣的背书，确实可能将事情推向更多的爱、宽恕和联系，或者更多的仇恨、极化和攻击。这听起来非常有趣。
I wish you all good luck in doing this research. I want to thank you for joining me today, Dr. X-Line. Thank you so much, Kim. This was really fun, and I appreciate having this opportunity to talk with you today. Thanks again. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, YouTube, or wherever you get, your favorite podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org.
祝愿你们在这些研究中一切顺利。我想感谢您今天加入我的节目，X-Line博士。非常感谢你，金。这真的很有趣，我很感谢今天有这个机会与你交谈。再次感谢。您可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Stitcher、YouTube 或任何您获取喜爱的播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）之前的剧集。如果您对未来的播客有任何评论或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。
Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《心理学谈话》由李·威纳曼（Lee Winerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪恩（Chris Condyenne）。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。